you're an internet kid where I think a
lot of guys especially the older guys
but with your generation like this is
it's not it's not going to get to you
because you came up with this of course
you know what I'm saying yeah and a lot
of kids now they have to deal with this
kind of [__] especially with bullying
and [__] like that so they think this is
forever like Jones was trying me like
two weeks ago just going at me online
and then I was enjoying my life but one
day
I had time so I just
online when you and Joan start talking
stuff and I assume because I've heard
you do interviews before he's the one
who came at you it doesn't make sense to
me he's the goat right now right and
you're the you're the the young kid
freshman I'm the Freshman with a belt
you know and when this when the Freshman
rolls up and he's getting all the
attention that you wish you could have
got he sees me shining now
we're in L.A baby crackheads everywhere
yeah I was a crackhead or she's an Izzy
fan crackers fan that's a game to play
both crackhead or is he Spanish music it
is